whoopi goldberg suspended from the view
for holocaust remarks this is a variety
story okay this is a variety story
um whoopi goldberg has been suspended
from the view for two weeks after facing
white criticism for her remarks that the
holocaust was not about race goldberg's
suspensions suspension was announced and
statement released by abc news public
relations tuesday night effectively
immediately i'm suspending we'll be over
for two weeks for her wrong and hurtful
comments reads a statement attributed to
kim godwin president at abc while whoopi
has apologized i've asked her to take
time to reflect and learn about the
impact of her comments the entire abc
news organization stands in solidarity
with our jewish colleagues friends
family and communities goldberg's
remarks emerged during a conversation on
monday's broadcast of the view in which
co-hosts discussed a tennessee school
boards bands of mouse a non-fiction uh
graphic novel about cartoonist art
spiegelman's father's experience
surviving the holocaust let's be
truthful about it because
the holy holocaust isn't about race said
goldberg
this is white people doing it to other
white people the holy scholar cause
isn't about race it's about a man's
inhumanity to man adam
i'm assuming you've seen her comments
and the banter back and forth what are
your thoughts yeah i um well this might
shock you i don't watch the view so it's
not like i'm surprised i know i know i
don't know
i do like jedidiah
yeah i'm not a fan of uh
whoopi or joy behar but
is there any
person who's more confused
than whoopi goldberg her last name is
goldberg that's pretty
chewy if you ask me
uh but yet she's not jewish but she kind
of hijacked the jewish name to kind of
be more palatable to hollywood i guess i
don't know understand but
she she's black but not saying that you
can't be black can't be jewish but then
i don't she i think she's not a lesbian
but she kind of looks like one i don't
know i don't want to get cancelled but i
don't know what she's got going on
but
the naivete
of her and the comments and then
her co-host just kind of let sitting
back and letting her go deeper and
deeper and not being like hey whoopi do
you want to just kind of back up a
second
they just
they let her kind of hang herself and
they gave her the rope um then
she went on colbert and doubled down on
the comments i don't know if you saw
that and colbert just kind of sat there
was like
okay coming up on break
anything else and then i think someone
ultimately got to her and they were like
whoopi i don't know what the hell you're
doing or whatever
but just shut up and read this script
and then she came out and she's like i
whoopi goldberg i do understand that
racism exists and you know these are my
words that i'm scripted so
again not a fan of the view i don't
watch the show this is sort of the
trickle-down effect of us hearing it by
hearsay but
what i will say about hitler is he
looked at at the jews as
not human that was his whole thing
and as a jew
it's funny because i don't
know many jews who just consider
themselves to be just white
again
jews in general
there's ashkenazi jews who are basically
uh that's me out of the eastern europe
poland russia
finland germany that area of country
then there's sephardic jews out of
morocco
the middle east iran for an example and
then there's ethiopian jews they're
basically you know just south of israel
in the middle east
so
to be jewish is not just a religion it's
a culture it's an ethnicity
it's
it's it's sort of all-encompassing i
don't know many jews that even if
they're white are like yeah i'm just a
white guy
um
there is something unique about being
jewish and
the
her comments were what exactly
the holocaust isn't about race it's
about all that it's about inhumanity
it's about race it's about ethnicity
it's about white power white supremacy
judaism arianism
uh
it's never good to start making these
types of comments and this is an example
why now i'm glad
that she's not
canceled for good
she's what suspended for two weeks
should she be cancer i do not think she
should she'd be fired i do not think she
should what did roseanne say
when she got fired what did roseanne say
when she got fired i'm curious
oh and she said uh what did roseanne say
she obviously made some
what was her comment when she got fired
go right there tweet roseanne barr
right there
show is being killed she talked about
valerie jarrett and looking kind of like
a monkey or something like an ape
is that what it was can you figure out a
way to find that the tweet just you know
just go to images just go to images
it'll show the tweet is this what it's
like when he drives as you guys barking
orders shoot the samantha you know what
it is this is like go left no no go
right so it's probably just as
frustrating on tyler as it is on us but
think about it just from before we find
this tweet click on that oh you got it
yeah let's see
uh i apologize to valerie no no i don't
know that's not
what it is the
the main one look at the
um
muslim brotherhood planet muslim
brotherhood and planet apes had a baby
it was valerie jarrett exactly what do
you what do you think about is that uh
fireball offense look man i think
we're so a comedian saying that would
you say roseanne's a comedian i don't
yes
uh a non-funny one but yeah she i agree
but she's a comedian right so she made a
comment like that which by the way
that's
a stupid
comment to make like she was also on the
sleeping pills i forget what they're
called whatever you're on though but
that's a dumb comment to make okay
there's nothing about this that to me
it's funny that's not funny to me when i
hear that right now if somebody thinks
it's funny it is what it is and what
whoopi said
obviously she's she wasn't trying to be
funny she was just now she talked like
she believed what she was talking about
what's funny is whippy used to be a
comedian i don't know if anyone would
define her as a comedian today she's too
serious she's too bitter yeah she made
her upset i don't know what's going on
with her but think about this for a
second here's the reason that that
you know we talk about joe rogan being
canceled i think more than anything the
first amendment
it doesn't it it's not there for the
speech you want to hear it's for the
speech that you don't want to hear and
that's the whole point of the first
amendment and just the the knee-jerk
reaction to cancel somebody
at the very least
now you can learn and people around you
can learn you know like
this is a off topic but remember when
michael vick
was basically removed from the nfl by
the way that's another one for changing
your reputation he's actually shown back
in the media that's my point
is that you can learn and get smarter
and better and improve that's what
sharon stone said and now he's really
and now he's an advocate
for dogs i mean i'm sure this is this
this is something that probably hits
close to home for you and not dog
fighting by the way can you do me a
favor type in sharon stone cancel
culture she may have explained cancer
culture better than
anybody else i've heard sharon stone out
of everybody uh
okay click on that so we can read it uh
uh uh
make it uh see if you can find your
comments according to
she believes if someone says something
or behaves in a way that you are
displeased with you can always try and
understand each other you can learn to
respect each other's opinion on
different matters she further explained
that people have struggled and done so
much
for you to cancel the person all because
they
did something you are not happy with go
lower uh go lower goal or to read the
rest of it yeah no she didn't just
express her opinions on the sake of
internet validation for the sake of
going against wanted to want some
profound reaction
anyways she she keeps continuing going
saying how are we supposed to learn of
each other if we don't argue how are we
supposed to learn more about each other
where you say something i'm offended
with i got to go do the research right
the part that here becomes the concern
is the following i got a question i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
so what is a bigger crime okay what is a
bigger crime what is more offensive
is it a bigger crime to ask
tough questions everyone's thinking
about or is it a bigger crime to make
dumb statements
what's a bigger crime is it a bigger
crime for me to ask
uh you know someone a direct question uh
you're dating and you're sitting are you
getting to the point that you're
thinking about you know maybe i'm gonna
call this guy my you know boyfriend or
girlfriend is it dumber to say hey let
me ask you a question last two
relationships how come they didn't work
out looks like both of them left you why
did they leave you okay that's a tough
question or is it worse to say you're
such a dog
okay
what's what's worse
number two either yeah to me to me it's
honestly neither as it relates to both
that that question and and these is that
i think we're where the majority of of
society who gets up in arms on either
side of the table on stuff like this
can't differentiate between something
that they don't like and something that
legitimately harms them
and i think that that's the the
benchmark that everybody should try to
adhere to when it comes to stuff like
this i don't think anybody should be
canceled or fired or whatever for stuff
like this especially when
it's somebody who is in in the media you
know if you're a comedian you're an
entertainer you're a big personality on
social media whether it's twitter or you
have your own radio show or whatever it
is is that you are out there in the
public expressing your opinions and
views and and people have the ability to
just not [ __ ] watch if they if they
don't like it i mean to me the nfl is
the same way
uh you know taking a knee or some of the
other controversies that they've had is
that i i don't think it should be
outlawed does it piss me off it does but
i have the choice to either watch the
nfl or not watch the nfl and i think
it's the same with the view i think it's
same with comedians i think it's same
with listening to joe rogan to me with
all this stuff it's really that black
and white is is that it's either all or
nothing you know you either decide we're
going to dictate what everybody can say
and and then we don't have a democracy
of freedom freedom of speech anything or
or you don't and you let people do what
they're going to do and you choose to to
listen or not i'll take a different
angle with this one okay i'll take a
different angle with the small world
whoopi okay
i think we'll be so necessary for media
i think she is so necessary uh i think a
lot of people don't like her but i think
whoopi needs to be there because whoopi
is a pushing buttons to get others to
sit there and say what the hell is she
talking about i think she needs to stay
i think whoopi the way she handled mel
gibson when mel gibson made the comments
this wasn't 2010 or 2011 when the view
that's a long time ago type in mel
gibson the view whoopi and see what year
comes up it could have been 2010 2011.
and she said look i i don't know what
happened there but here's what i can
tell 2010 when she made that right that
whoopee defense goldberg 2010 go to the
bottom one cbs news yeah when she
defended we'll pick over defense mel
gibson on the view okay so go up and if
you guys remember this was not like a
just i don't like what he did here but i
know mel and i know he's not racist
the view on the monday he may be a
bonehead i can't sit and say that he's a
racist having spent time with him in my
house with my kids
if someone's kicking your behind and
punching you while you're holding your
kid you don't go to the cops first you
go to raider online goldberg said
anyways
so you know mel made a few comments
and she defended him okay she just kind
of came out and said i don't know and by
the way there was another guy
who was a very big actor he was on there
as well full-on republican he was on the
view
and he disagrees with whoopi so i think
whoopi has friends on the opposing side
but i just think she made a very
bonehead uh mistake with the comments
you make and you have to realize that
hollywood is ran by
jews so you you're making a comment to
the point where a lot of these
executives you know the whole history of
hollywood started by who so that you you
just got to be very careful with some of
the comments you're making but i don't
think she needs to be canceled i think
she needs to stay on the view on but
knowing what's going on today
if i'm a betting man i'm leaning more
towards her getting fired than her not
getting fired you're shaking your head
for a minute we didn't think cuomo was
gonna get fired he did for a minute we
didn't think zucker would ever get fired
he did for a moment we thought chris
chromo would never get fired he did
these are all people on the left by the
way so so to have your own selective
hearing conservative side to say they
would never fire her they would keep her
i think they're probably leaning towards
firing her i hope they don't but what's
the benefit of firing whoopi i we did it
we got rid of her
dumb comments will no longer happen like
you're never going to create a safe
space
that you're never going to create this
echo chamber that everybody gets to hear
everything that they want and no
disagreement and no arguments that's the
whole point of what we're doing here in
america is that we're never going to
always get along but talk it out figure
it out and if everyone just doesn't feel
safe to say what's on their mind now
we're not
basically living under the first
amendment and it's freedom of speech and
now it's like you're walking on
eggshells i don't want to say that here
are my thoughts and then it just becomes
a china thing or an iran thing or you
can't even say what's on your [ __ ]
mind that's crazy and the best thing
that'll come after this whoopee thing
just like the michael vick thing is that
she'll learn from it and that people
will be like whoopi you gotta understand
that this and it should
and only progress will happen from this
not saying what's on your mind no
progress will happen we know the jewish
holocaust museum reached out to her to
say we'd like to invite you to simon
wiesenthal yeah they invited us
to invite you to come here let us share
with you the history i think if whoopi
goes there and she shows the effort i
think that's a great example for
americans i wonder if they addressed it
as dear mrs goldberg would you like to
the irony here so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you